alright let's get started hello everyone
thank you for coming those of you who
are here in the room as well as those
who are tuning in on the live stream
my name is Vivek bald and I'm an
associate professor and comparative
Media Studies and the director of
Graduate Studies for CMS today we'll be
providing you with information about the
CMS master's degree program I'll start
with a brief overview of the program and
then you'll hear from faculty members
lab managers current second year masters
student and so and with any luck we'll
also have different members of the
faculty and research research groups
kind of moving in and out over time over
the course of the two hours as their
schedules permit so the the and we have
a live chat
you compare their video studies and
writing YouTube channel you can find the
link on our website or just search for
it on YouTube okay great so so the
master's program and comparative Media
Studies was founded in 1999 with our
first cohort graduating in 2001 this
means that you're nearing 20 years of
graduates at which point there will be
around 150 of our former students
working in academia
TEKT journalism gaming film and
entertainment and the nonprofit sector
so what kind of program is comparative
Media Studies broadly speaking our
program addresses the challenges brought
about by fundamental shift in practices
of media production distribution
consumption at a local national and
global scale we see this work as a
particularly urgent at a time of ever
accelerating technological and social
change rather than focus on media
specific silos games films social media
computational cetera we explore the
dynamics of media and societal change
through a comparative historical and
multidisciplinary lens so this means in
essence well that the reason for the
word comparative in the title of our
program is that since the founding of
CMS our faculty labs in the curriculum
have all emphasized critical analyses of
the role of media society that are
comparative comparative across different
media forms spaces communities and
practices across different historical
periods across different local and
global cultural and sub cultural
contexts utilizing methodologies that
are drawn from
these social sciences and computational
Sciences while also drawing upon the
insights of different forms of media
production and practice our faculty labs
and researchers reflect that diversity
in the approach to critical analyses of
media among our faculty and researchers
you'll find individuals who are
primarily media practitioners others who
are primarily media scholars and
theorists and others who combine media
scholarship and practice in their work
this is a particularly productive even
heady mix the conversations and
collaborations that it fosters are what
makes MIT s comparative Media Studies
program a uniquely generative space for
scholarship research and graduate study
the research groups themselves are part
of what makes the CMS program unique we
currently have nine research under the
umbrella of comparative Media Studies
each one of which is engaged at the
intersection of critical media research
and practice some of these are labs led
by our faculty members with funding from
various granting agencies others are led
by research scientists whom we have a
couple representatives to talk about
their work today as well and the
majority of master's students are funded
for their two years at CMS either
through work that they do in one of
these our search groups or through
research assistantships with specific
faculty members outside of
each year the program is further
enriched by visiting scholars and
practitioners visitors are often
associated with specific research groups
and often they will also teach a course
as part of their time here so this is
also a great opportunity to learn from
the talented people who are passing
through each year our two-year
curriculum is a mix of required
foundations courses and electives that
students can choose from within
CMS's broader offerings the electives
from within
CMS's offerings or in some cases from
other schools and departments at MIT or
even in some cases from Harvard
University through MIT s consortium
relationship there are many additional
details about each course online so I
encourage you to explore those on on our
website in the first year series theory
and methods and major media texts which
you see here in the first four semester
help provide a shared language and a
shared grounding given the diversity of
students in the program some of whom are
coming from primarily scholarly
backgrounds who recently out of
undergraduate work and some of whom are
coming from various fields within you
know media media industries or are
engaged as media practitioners for a
number of years before entering the
program so these foundational courses
kind of bring everyone on to roughly the
same page in terms of shared language to
talk about media and the analysis of
media as well as a series of shared
foundational texts for her students to
kind of build
[Music]
you'll see that there is also a hands-on
component to the first-year curriculum
in the first year this course comes
through a workshop class workshop one in
which students are exposed to and engage
in various forms of media production and
research practice associated with
different CMS faculty and labs then in
the second semester and this is a fairly
new change to our curriculum students
then choose from a small selection of
workshop based courses that focus on
specific forms of media production such
as game production documentary film etc
another key part of the student
experience at CMS is our weekly
colloquium each week CMS hosts speakers
to present recent and ongoing research
in a variety of fields of media analysis
and production in some cases our own
faculty researchers and alumni present
their work in the colloquium and in
others we draw on the many media
scholars and practitioners who are
moving through the Boston Cambridge area
or in some cases who we bring in from
across the country and across the world
the second year in the the curriculum
offers students the opportunity to take
more electives focused on their specific
areas of interest while working on their
master's thesis the thesis occupies an
increasing amount of time and focus for
the students in the second year
with the second semester of the second
year devoted largely to its writing
under the guidance of a thesis advisor
and an additional reader these advisors
thesis advisors are usually drawn from a
core faculty and in some cases students
choose to faculty as Co advisors to draw
upon their you know different strengths
of different types so some students have
also included elements of media
production as part of their thesis
projects in addition to their written a
thesis our students have done truly
impressive work in their thesis projects
on a really wide range of topics so I
encourage you again to take the time to
look at the list of recent theses on the
CMS website in addition these species
have formed the foundation of a wide
range of books that CMS faculty
particularly those alumni who have gone
into the academic field have gone on to
publish after their time here in the
program these are just a few of the
examples one of them makers from
Bollywood from Bombay to Bollywood and
as Collison's how climate change comes
to matter I need to say chance
networking periphery Kevin Driscoll's
mini tell Ryan Jacobson studios before
system and Whitney threatens gas star
so I also encourage you to spend some
time looking at the fullest
full list of alumni at the link listed
here they are talented bunch who have
used their study research writing and
production in the CMS program as a
launching pad for work in an array of
different so that's my brief
introduction there's plenty of time
there gonna be plenty of time for for
questions to elaborate on any one of
these aspects of the program but now I'd
like to hand things off to some of our
faculty researchers and students who
introduce themselves and each of them
will talk to you about the our the work
that they do here and their own
experiences and perspectives on the CMS
graduate program so I think Heather will
start with you and then great thanks for
Vic so I'm Heather Hendershot I'm a
professor of film and media as my
official title within the CMS program
I've been here since 2012 and most of my
research is on right-wing media both
historical and contemporary and
basically I'm a media historian very
archival a based in a digital moment or
era or apocalypse whatever digital
moment we're in I'm in the archive
looking through papers and files and
dusty things and sneezing and looking
for that River real needle in a haystack
for for exciting historical moments to
write about um I started my career
writing about children's television did
two books in that area before I got
shifting gears there were some
connections between children's
television right wing media that might
not be immediately obvious but I was
working on censorship and issues of
cultural politics and actually the
transition was pretty smooth my two most
recent books are one it's called a
what's fair on the air cold war right
wing broadcasting in the public interest
so it is about the right wing
broadcasting boom
of the 60s and 70s and how the FCC shut
that down and it's a kind of interesting
kind of prehistory of Fox News in a
certain way what how right-wing news
what not what right knee wing news look
like before the deregulation of the
Reagan years enabled Rush Limbaugh and
later Fox and so on to come along my
most recent book is called open to
debate how William F Buckley put liberal
America on the firing line so it is
about a television show that ran from
1966 to 1999 hosted by William F Buckley
one of the fathers of the American
contemporary conservative movement and
it was a show in which people from the
left and the right had they argued a
little bit but mainly they didn't scream
at each other they had debates they had
real conversation and so it was
obviously a book in which I was making a
kind of plea for civility and looking at
the kind of a model for how that might
happen which might seem very naive but
we must hold out hope that we could talk
to each other like sane and rational
people and this show really showed how
that could be done for 33 years so that
was that was the focus of that book and
right now I'm researching a book on the
Chicago Democratic National Convention
of 1968 the media coverage of that
convention the fallout from that and
that was a peak moment where people
conservatives accused the media of bias
and they didn't call it fake news but
they said words that kind of added up to
that in certain ways so it's a pivot
moment for thinking about accusations of
media being or the news specifically
being unfair being biased and slanted
and so on and I actually recently wrote
a piece for Politico exactly on this so
if you want to get a sense of what do I
write what does it look like what's the
style etc you can find my recent piece
on Politico on
the NCO 68 here at CMS I teach the
theories and methods to class these I've
put up that nice chart to show you your
two years of study here and so theories
and methods to is the follow-up to
theories and methods one which you would
take in the fall here and then in the
spring you would take my class and it
would culminate with the production of
your thesis proposal your master's
thesis proposal and it's a course that
teaches about methods but also helps you
to think about style and narrative and
structure and how to conceptualize
conceptualize yourself as a writer and a
researcher and helping you to think
through not just what do you want to
write but why do you want to write it
why is it important and how do you want
to write it how do you want to tell the
story who's your audience and how can
you craft your prose to appeal to and
engage that audience so that's what we
do in that class I'll give you a heads
up that I'm going to be on leave next
year so I won't be teaching that class
but I will be available for contact you
want to reach out to talk to me about
your interests and so on I also like all
of our faculty I'm available for
advising theses in the past we've
actually showed one I advised recently
too one was about the politics of
contemporary comedy it was called
everything is awful it's about snark you
might have noticed that one at the
bottom and then there was another one on
Trump's use of social media that I was
the lead advisor on I've in the past of
ICC's on ranging from like podcasts and
the television industry and how it
affects writers and the writer unions
and so on to working with a student
working on educational technology use in
New York City public schools so I can
work with you on a thesis in a lot of
different areas that said I'd be
delighted to work with any budding
archival media historians because that's
my sort of home base and my expertise
and I would love to share that with you
I will add I don't think we've had
mentioned that
the feces are on chenna you can confirm
this they're posted online right and how
did how would they find them from the
website they can find almost all of them
through the CMS W website or they can
look at the library archive called D
space okay okay good so if you want to
take a look at I don't know if I should
say hundreds of theses many theses
posted online and just see the range of
work that's been done in the past and
also it helps you with sort of questions
about style or how long are these things
are things that we can answer your
questions about but it's nice to
actually look at the thesis themselves
and get a sense of what your crowning
project would be at the end of your two
years and we kind of open by saying
you're gonna be writing a thesis I think
because it's such a fast-paced program
and when people ask me and were you
looking for an applicant I often say
well we don't want someone who knows
exactly what their thesis is to such an
extent that they could just write it
tomorrow they don't even need our
program because they've got it all
sorted out it's good to come in with
intellectual curiosity and flexibility
but that said having you know knowing
the area you want to work in knowing
some of the specifics having a good idea
of what your research focus will be if
not every detail of your thesis is it's
going to make your application stronger
because the program is so quick that if
you come in totally rudderless you're
you're going it's gonna be hard for us
to help you get that rudder going the
right way so we're here to help you with
the writer I'm this metaphor is gonna
just say
at the moment but it helps have some
sense of what you're up to before you
get here you know so you can hit the
ground running I guess it's what I'm
saying I think that's all I have to say
gives you a little idea of what I do and
I actually was the director of Graduate
Studies until just a few months ago and
so I'm a good resource for you to get in
touch with if you have any sort of
nitty-gritty questions about how the
program functions as well as feedback
and of course Shannon who knows
everything a supercomputer so I'm
Michael Jacobson I'm the research
coordinator for the MIT game lab one of
the research labs under CMS I'll try to
do this from a potential grad student
perspective so I teach a number of
classes one of them is introduction to
game studies we all the six or seven
classes that the game lab teaches has
more students wanting to take them than
we can take so for that one if there's a
graduate student in the program who is
interested in game studies they can
serve as as my TA for that class I also
teach a class for graduate students
called playful and social interaction
the science of my background is in
informatics and then interaction design
and then I've here so it's a studio
based class where students come with an
idea of a project they want to do and we
spend the semester helping each other
realizing that project and we do a lot
of readings and discussions around doing
research through design what that means
what kind of results you could expect
and so we run a number of research
projects in the lab last summer we went
to Columbia and toured a summer class
for
computer science students who are doing
we are but our perspective on the class
was how to integrate their lived
experiences in making games that are
related to Columbia in some sense
because there's a lot of games out there
both video games and board games that
take place in Columbia and presumably or
about Columbia but they're not really
about Columbia ever so that grew out of
a book project I'm working on on
colonialists themed board games and we
brought a graduate student on our trip
to work with us as basically a research
assistant and teaching assistant for
that we also went to Puerto Rico and did
a workshop there with professional game
designers but very much with the same
kind of purpose of making coming up with
concepts and Mechanics for more
interesting games about Puerto Rico than
what's out there so today we have also
started a project where we will be
working with Native American tribes in
northern Maine so there are three tribes
there that are interested in
collaborating with us again with similar
purpose using game design workshops as a
way for not just presenting aspects of
their lives that would be of interest
and importance for the rest of us to
know more about but also to help build
self-image and help convey a more real
concept of the life that these people
are living other projects involved we're
working together with a Swedish game
developer called King they are mostly
known for making
called candy crush and we're doing we're
making a digital tool web-based tool
which is meant to increase reflection
and awareness around a inclusivity in
the creation of videogame characters so
it's basically a tool that you can input
a concept for a character you're
creating it gives you an interactive
visualization of different aspects of
inclusivity in that character and you
can modify it and adjust it and have
communications or discussions about what
if we tried something that is less well
represented within our studio or within
the genre or in game design in general
so part of that has been running
workshops both in Sweden and here both
for game developers and for students and
we use graduate students from our
program and from Harvard who came with
us and helped us facilitate these
workshops and participate in writing
papers about the outcomes so I think
that's a fairly good representation of
what the grad student involvement is in
our activities also those in the mission
statement of of the game lab we say that
we teach game design we study games we
make games we are a functioning game
development studio usually when we work
with other game companies we don't make
games because they already know how to
do that but often we have other
companies who are interested in having a
game made thats related to directive it
is but that's not their expertise to
them they come to us and then we are the
developers but on top of all of that we
also think that it's really
important to play games if you stop
playing games we think that you drift
away from understanding games on a very
basic fundamental level so we try to
play games every week and it's open for
the graduate students to join us and
it's not always fun games I mentioned
the colonialist team board games project
there's a lot of racism and slavery and
horrendous stuff going on in those games
but but it's still I think interesting
to seeing all these different mechanics
and types of games play out and be able
to do a critical analysis from a
first-time experience drop Scott Oswald
the creative director of both the
education of Caden in the game have a
background originally theater in
television then it's games for the last
25 years the education Arcada and begin
might overlap significantly because you
both to work on games education Erik
Cade was founded in 2000 basically to do
look at issues around games and learning
it is itself situated inside the teacher
education program at MIT which is a
program largely for undergraduates all
the graduates in the state sometimes
participate but that prepares students
to be teachers and so we have this sort
of double focus of teaching preparing
people to be teachers and thinking about
schools as systems with sort of more I
would say open-ended looking into
educational technology and its uses the
stuff we do around game design that I
always know it's important to say that
the problem with our educational game is
that it often conjures up an image at
school and I think generally what we
my knowledge of models and learning they
are not like what we think of this and
solve the games that we do don't try to
replicate school just dress them up with
bright colors and funny sounds but
rather really get we hold with the
thesis of wrath posture that what makes
any game interesting is learning is
learning the game and so if we're doing
a game for it to care for learning we're
making we're trying to make sure that
it's a game that's learning the game
that is the interesting thing we just
try and make that coterminous with
learning something that never at the
same time me kids already start
described well how graduate students are
largely involved in the design work that
we do and as he said it's designed
research we make we actually make
product that sometimes gets out there it
actually is good to be out in the world
but we're always sometimes not sometimes
it's an experiment but either case we're
always as we make it we're trying to
learn from it try to have some impact on
your field we just published if you're
interested in this space and you want to
understand kind of work we do we just
publish the book and I keep restaurant
and just published a book called
resident games and that gives you pretty
good overview of what we do also I think
like most research manager she will tell
you I enjoy also advising NPCs when I
can and generally I find that however
interesting my work is it's more
interesting if I'm working with students
graduates that's what we're here for
we're not here just to do the work with
your it doesn't work with you
[Music]
yeah I'm Sarah woloson and I'm from the
MIT open documentary lab we study and
interesting new forms of storytelling
using emerging technologies reality
augmented reality artificial
intelligence and when I say storytelling
I already have to correct myself
because many people argue that in
virtual reality you're not telling
stories people are story finding you're
creating story experiences when you're
creating dialogue but what it is doing
is really essentially changing the role
of the authors of subjects in the
audience because it's much more
collaborative interactive so it's a
different kind of documentary and we
build the field we have resources we
have a doctor base which is a database
of the trends and the people projects
and tools changing the landscape we have
a project called moments of innovation
which traces the whole history of
documentary and innovation we have a
publication immerse on medium which we
did together with Tribeca Film Institute
and that just is a platform
a place for dialogue around emerging
media types and now most recently we
have a co-creation studio that we
launched about a year and a half ago and
we have a we just had a big symposium
about co-creation methodologies and
we're also were in the process of
writing a big field study about
co-creation methodology so those are
some some of the projects we do rad
students they work like ties right
alonga
and it depends really what our labs
doing so we do a lot of different
projects and every year there can be a
different project I can tell you right
now we're really focused on the field
study and so the grad students are doing
research on that particular right now
visual inventory that we need for the
study when we had the symposium they'll
help with that your two years ago we had
one of virtual reality and it was very
much based on a grad students expertise
that he had developed writing a thesis
so he really had
and in curating the whole symposium
we're had the students also go to
Sundance every year there's always a
little person students place as pres
which means they get a much better path
than I think they can get into
everything and they write about this
section called the new frontier which is
the section of Sundance which looks at
technology and they also always work on
docu base that's a really important
resource for the field there's really
nothing like it if you want to even know
what this build is go there and actually
we have the student right here potential
students worked on it all summer on the
taxonomy so yeah and so those are those
are some of the things they do we also
run a lot of workshops yeah a lot of
lectures oh yeah we thank you we have a
big Fellows Program which is very
exciting we have people come in from all
over the world and locally who are
experimenting with a documentary whether
it's from a maker point of view or from
a scholar point of view I'm studying it
and it creates a really vibrant
community for the students too
some students have even ended up
collaborating with our fellows they're
very experienced
career professional and we meet weekly
and we have lectures we have a guest
lecture every week from somewhere near
aiya tea somewhere in the world from a
variety of fields whether its web PR or
an interactive street music platform
[Music]
experience I guess applying to the
program what do you program so I was
sitting where you were two years ago
yeah was two years ago and I took a lot
of time to think whether to apply or not
to see if it was right fit for me I
already had coming into this several
years of college
professional career professionally a DJ
curator produce events also had some
experience adjunct thing teaching in the
university so I saw this program and I
talked to a lot of people some
professors here as well as some alumni
to see if it was a good fit for me and
ultimately if it's great fit and what's
great about the program here is its what
what was conveyed in the opening
statement is that it's really what you
make of it and there's a lot of
directions you can go in and there's a
lot of resources there's a lot it the
there's a lot of collaboration here I
think one of the for me the best parts
are you can take almost any class at
Harvard which is which is great as a
great option especially
MIT is stem driven so there are some
sometimes other classes there that that
are great classes here are also pretty
awesome and it's very structured the
first semester a little less structured
the second semester and then by the
second year you're in full swing with
your thesis work and then you can take
courses as you need to to get to your
thesis goal and the thing is if you do
come in here you will walk out with with
with with something with a thesis which
is gonna be useful whatever direction
you go into my thesis that I'm working
on now is about women DJ's a feminist
approach to deejaying as a cultural
practice so my fieldwork will be mostly
in New York and and I'm also gonna do
the option of creating a companion media
piece with it I'll be making a podcast
with it as well
in terms of the lab I'm working directly
as an RA for professor because they all
who was affiliated with OD Allison's so
it's like it's also being part of the
odl community open doc lab community but
specifically working with the vague I'm
working on a platform he's creating as a
addition to a documentary book project
lost a home four hours ago lost
histories which is an interactive
platform for people to contribute
content and stories
connected to his book Bengali Harlem I'm
also helping research do research for
him for grants managing a project
managing that as well as like working
the you know some of the work tech
people
developing the platform so it's really
it's pretty good solid experience and I
and it's really interesting as well the
weekly colloquiums are are pretty cool
too there's food every week the end of
the colloquium there's a lot of food on
this campus all the time food care yes
there's this thing called food cam and
there's also an email list by the time
you get the email but there's this area
livestream oh yeah but I just have the
tab open you can just check out the
Holies to Heather I was like plastic
containers in office she's always tough
we're just yeah sometimes during member
week it gets pretty big so food cam is
basically it's it's there's an area in
the building where where a lot of our
classes are it's connected to the media
lab complex there's an area where people
leave extra food out and there's a
camera pointed to it and it gets a
button is pressed and that picture is
sent out to use email list that's a
zombie apocalypse just oh yeah
and you know you'll just be sitting
around also and you see people running
by you they're like that food camp a lot
of yeah that's the only reason you
should apply I mean I think the reason
why I decided to come especially as
someone who's already had a career in
wanting to sort of expand my knowledge
or be more critical about what I had
done
what I was working on was because it's
interdisciplinary and even though
there's some foundational courses which
I think are really great
to get you started it's really what you
make of it there's a lot of stuff that
happens in the community and the area
here between I mean that's one of the
challenges it's like there's so much
going on the talks and every lab most
labs have weekly meetings which are also
some of them are open to the public
the university you know MIT does talks
there's a lot of there's a lot of
intellectual and cultural culturally
rich activities here but if there's
anything specific that you want to ask
me
extremely tempting I'm Justin Reich I'm
a new assistant professor here I run a
lab called the teaching systems lab
along with Eric Klopfer we're sure to
Eric Klopfer has been here for 20 years
but recently moved into comparative
Media Studies and we're both really
interested in learning media of how
media are used to help develop people's
capacity in all kinds of different ways
to divide fractions to teach kids to be
more effective civic actors all kinds of
things so my background is I was a
former classroom teacher and then got a
doctorate down the river at Harvard
looking at large-scale online learning
systems when when Harvard X got started
I helped
start up their research lab and build
the research infrastructure there so
I've been interested in in teaching and
large-scale learning for a long time but
now my interests are really combining
those so a lot of what we do in our lab
is investigate how it is that we
couldn't take we imagine that all around
the world people want to see more
ambitious teaching and learning
happening in k-12 classrooms they want
to see less passive learning your
recitations more active engaged
student-centered learning and we think
the only way that will happen is if we
can dramatically increase the quantity
and quality of learning experiences that
are available to teachers throughout
their lifetime and because teachers are
incredibly busy people including one of
the things we ask them to do is to keep
track of all the children so if you put
all the teachers in one part of the
building but the kids are roaming free
any other part of the building that
online a blended learning will be an
essential part of building that capacity
so my lab is a super interdisciplinary
place we have teacher educators and
learning scientists and game designers
and people who do work in evaluation and
measurement we do a lot of design
research where we build things we put it
into the field in various kinds of ways
we've had a bunch of partnerships last
year with most of the major national
computer science professional
development organizations like code.org
and exploring computer science and
mobile computing design principles we we
have a new project this year that we're
working with teacher educators from
around the country so we have a program
called the inspire or fellowship
innovative new spaces for practice and
rehearsal and teacher education coming
up with acronyms is like 90% of what we
do and then the other 10% is putting
things in the field now but we have 13
teacher educators from UT Austin and
William and Mary and UMass Dartmouth and
Oakland University in really big schools
really small schools and places where
teacher educators jobs is to do a lot of
research and a little bit of teaching in
places where their job is to do a lot of
teaching and we have folks coming to our
lab and look at
some of the tools that we're using for
online and blended learning experiences
teachers to take them back to their
different and diverse context do
research with us and to figure out how
we can develop and refine some of those
ideas so that's sort of a sampling of
some of the kinds of things that we do
but but all all of its built on the idea
of thinking about how we take new forms
of learning media how do we build things
put them in the world that developed a
cap capacity of teachers both in the US
and around the world I'll speak about my
myself as a faculty member as well so
I've been here four years now
my my background like like Rica I went
to graduate school after having been
involved in various forms of media and
cultural production
I worked for about a dozen years as a
documentary filmmaker before getting a
degree that was essentially a kind of
interdisciplinary Cultural Studies
degree and then was hired here right
after that and my work as a filmmaker
and as a scholar now is really focused
on the histories and experiences of
South Asian immigrants and migrants to
the US and Britain
kind of navigation of the two sort of
imperial powers of the United States and
and Britain and both during the colonial
period and the post-colonial period so
my first documentary film focused on
South Asian immigrant taxi drivers in
New York City in the early 1990s at a
point in time where South Asian
immigrants had become the largest of
within the taxi driving industry my
second documentary focused on South
Asian and youth and music and
anti-racist politics in Britain in the
1990s it focused on a generation of
South Asia and youth whose parents were
brought to the to Britain or encouraged
to come to Britain basically to rebuild
Britain after the Second World War and
grew up as you know working-class
Britons of color at a time when also you
know they were surrounded by beginnings
of hip-hop and punk rock and Jamaican
music etc so that documentary film
focused on generation of musicians that
combine all those forms of music both
with South Asian music Anthony and
racist activism my current project that
I've been working on here for the last
several years is consists of a book a
documentary and a web platform that I
can mentioned that are all focused in
different ways on recovering the history
of one of the earliest communities of
Muslim immigrants to the United States
were undocumented immigrants
from what is now predominantly from
what's now Bangladesh who settled in in
US cities at the time of the Asian
exclusion laws and integrated into
African American and Porto Rican
communities and created these
interracial families that whose second
generation are now in their 60s and 70s
so that project as I mentioned that was
the basis for a book that I published in
2013 called
Bengali Harlem in the lost histories of
South Asian America and I'm currently
working on a documentary film project
that follows the son of one of one of
the early violent Bengali migrants to
settle in Harlem as he tries to uncover
his father's and then his mother's
stories and then this web platform which
is we're designing as a kind of a space
of collective collective community
storytelling centered around family
photographs where photographs are being
used not as a kind of an end point but
as an ending point for or telling
stories memories etc and kind of
collectively you know collectively
asserting that the that these family
photographs are in fact historical
documents and that the people in these
photographs are historical actors it's
in a sense a kind of digital people's
history project I also am a faculty
member of the open documentary lab and
has been very enriched in my
participation in the in the weekly
programming and I teach within the
program I teach courses in documentary
film production there's one that's kind
of a basic production class that's
focused on a short web-based documentary
is called a short attention span in
documentary and another class that I
teach on a regular basis is called
social justice and documentary film and
that is kind of a combination of
critical analysis of recent social
justice documentaries as well as a group
project in which three or four students
together you know groups of three or
four work over the course of the
semester we a fairly decent now kit of
equipment to produce a short social
justice focused documentary I also teach
a course on South Asians history and
media representations
in the United States and more recently
have been developing of course that's
really centered on black British
cultural studies which while my work has
been in South Asian Diaspora studies has
been kind of the grounding for my own
kind of theoretical approach toward
should we open it up to questions
[Music]
questions and cookies yes
it's the Microsoft Research like Nancy
thing yeah with Nancy Baymen and yeah I
mean it's not that we see each other
every day but there is a relationship
and and several of our students have
worked with researchers over there and
they they come and present at our
colloquium inaud some of our faculty
present there so there's a kind of nice
back and forth
yet arcade
to develop material technologies at this
point
and think about me and technology
no I it's the latter I mean I think we
occasionally and a lot of it's driven by
the funding so occasionally we're doing
a project that is specifically designed
for schools I would say where possible
even we're doing something for schools
we're thinking about how can this sort
of change the definition of what
schooling is so we frequently do games
where maybe they're largely played
outside of school and there's some sort
of touch points that bring it into the
classroom we're trying to be as broad as
possible in our definition of what
learning is
the program
you
one
it's it's a bit of a mix oh yeah so the
question is it has to do with the
relationship between the research groups
and the curriculum and the experience of
taking courses writing a thesis etc so
all of the students are either placed
with or with a research group or with an
individual faculty member because there
are some faculty members who are doing
doing work that that is not within the
the structure of one of the research
group and the as part of the admissions
process the admissions committee and
others try to do their best to match up
students with particular interests to
place them in research groups where
their interests will be we'll kind of
have a fertile ground really and in some
cases the research groups are
specifically you know looking for you
know have spots for for incoming
graduate students so we try to again
place you find a good match and so in
terms of how it you know your your work
within a research group does not
necessarily have to be directly
connected to your thesis
and you know that that connection and I
think it probably varies from one
student to another yeah me too sometimes
it happens that the work that we need to
have done and the research group has
blended very little to of your thesis I
mean as much as we try to make you know
it is a worthwhile experience to be to
be our being an RA in a research group
but sometimes there's work that has to
get done with it maybe it's no interest
to you one way in habit yeah yeah and
and you know it's part of a financial
ecosystem that's kind of complicated but
the bottom line is it's your job while
you're here that gives you your monthly
stipend covers your tuition and your
health insurance so and and the last
stage of our of our committee meaning to
decide who's going to be admitted is you
know we get it down from a hundred
applicants our typical pool to you know
to 50 to 40 to 20 and then once we're 20
they're all great and we have 8 to 10
slots and we're like okay who can match
where and who's the best match for the
research lab to make sure that they're
funded and so on because we don't want
to bring it any one unfunded we want
everyone to be on equal footing and have
the same financial situation hitting the
ground here the only thing I can add to
that is definitely in our lab we have
some people
related and some not and sometimes when
it is it can even count as their
research hours so you know you have the
commitment of 20 hours a week because it
funded but I've also seen the opposite
someone who wanted to be in the
education arcade and by the time they
were into their thesis their interests
had shifted and that's fine too it's not
you're not you're not we don't we're not
committing you to any any thesis topic
by putting you in a research group I
also think this is probably student side
maybe you don't want to be doing your
thesis 20 hours a week in a lab and then
as much time did you meet you outside so
for me it's hard to say I like that what
I'm doing I find what I'm I feel
fortunate with work I'm doing the Vegas
is interesting of interest to me but
it's different and I'm actually building
or actually refreshing some previous
skills I had which I think will help me
when I graduate which is web project man
I've been which I did like 20 minutes
most people most people stay in the same
lab the whole time and we we actually
discourage a shift of labs sometimes it
happens for reasons they have to do with
the lab itself or the student or
whatever but that's something we really
try to minimize we like the continuity
of once you're here that is your life or
your two years all the labs are open to
you as an attendee we have a student
that Justin's lab who discovered when
she got here that she was really
interested in the open documentary lab
and so she does her work in and the
teaching assistants lab and attends the
odl meetings and so we really encourage
our students to cross pollinate as much
as they want to
so I would do especially when during
such
by variety and I was like angle
that's a that's a good question and it
varies I think the approach of various
varies from course to course so that for
example in workshop 1 you know it's a
it's a hands-on kind of orientation and
people working together in groups
whether they are designing a board game
or designing an app or whatever they
might be doing there's this
collaborative process where as
ultimately the thesis is something you
do on your own it's an individual
research project is sort of conventional
in that way it might be sort of
different than the kind of work you do
after graduation if you go into industry
and so in some classes you'll be writing
your own research paper that you did on
your own and you might share it with
your cohort or spend for feedback or
spend so on but but it's it's a more
conventional individually designed
project so I bet kind of just gets the
tip of the iceberg I think of your
question but maybe it's a good starting
point if people others have anything to
add I mean I think that that combination
from my standpoint in their courses that
I've taught that combination has been a
really fruitful one really
and you know I taught one of the
workshop classes when there was a second
semester workshop - and we worked on a
project collectively that was about kind
of charting the first hundred days of
Trump's presidency and there were people
who brought skills to that who were
documentary skills right and others who
really wanted to learn those documentary
skills who then work together as smaller
units within the class there were there
was someone with a building skills who
built a kind of a game that was part of
this larger project and so each person
was able both to kind of contribute to
that class based on their skills but
also to extend those skills through sort
of working collaboratively with others
that's the ideal and I mean I think Rica
I don't know whether you want to talk
about that from the students student
perspective what it's been yeah my
cohort is we come there's eight of us
and experiment some people have you know
worked already 10 plus years some people
are closer to being
graduates from undergrad and everybody
brings something different to the table
and it's really it works I mean I think
it's very helpful and in terms of the
actual the workshop one class is very
collaborative you work in groups the
other courses that I have taken so far
not so much but there's a collegiate
atmosphere mental people need help or
like you know we need we ask each other
you know for alcohol whatever that we
need to so it's it's there I mean it's
it's it's pretty small cohort so the
first year you're in every class
together so so you are working together
closely even if you're not collaborating
on each assignment
and then depending on what courses you
take in your electives like I know the
second semester you have to do a
workshop type classes hands-on class and
depending on what kind of class you take
I know some people took courses where
they were put again in groups and stuff
and in other classes yeah and that's the
class I guess your second semester
you've got Shannon there shorts out too
but there's also an elective right
there's no workshop - well there's our
hands-on class yeah so that's right so
that's where you might end up working
outside of your cohort your home bases
your your fellow students and what we're
referring to confusingly as workshop -
is that it used to be a class called
workshops here and then what we did was
switch it to make it more flexible so
that students would have more options
and not do every single thing with their
cohort if they didn't want to and so we
gave them a mist of managed electives of
hands-on production oriented type
courses to choose from with the
understanding that if you find something
else like some once-only class at
Harvard for example that is a bit that
is out there you come in ask us if it's
okay and nine times out of ten we say
yes I did that I took electronic
electronic music which is production
based course so
it was
and again that that kind of is based on
on funding and on kind of cycling there
a particular research group might have
funding for one person and so one person
is in that spot for two years and then
when that person graduated right and
there are other groups that might have
more funding one year and less funding
another year and so open up in terms of
they may be at but in the next cycle
they might need a three and some some
groups are much more consistent and
they'll take once
and every year but in its variable
at the moment no because we don't know
we don't know their status and probably
[Music]
well a couple things one is that and
this is just something that I advise all
students applying to graduate school
both our program and other programs in
terms of your approach to your statement
right is is to you know give us a sense
of like of what your trajectory has been
what is it taking you to the point at
which you feel in that trajectory you
want to you know spend two years
exploring something in a graduate
program and then what you see as
potentially the next step in your
trajectory so you know we kind of it
helps us when we're looking at the
applications to have a sense of where
you've been where we fit and
you know why you think our program is
the right fit for you at this point or
at least a strong option for you and
what you imagine yourself doing with
this this experience of graduate school
and so you know for those people who
have been out of school for a period of
time you know that period is you know
there's obviously there's something that
in that that 10 years you've come to a
point where you want to do this and I
was in the same situation when I apply
to graduate school I've been out for
about 12 years and I tried to convey you
know what it was that that was you know
driving me to do the work that I had
done in the past 12 years but what was
it about that that brought me to this
point and you know in general I feel
like you know those students who have
been out of formal educational
environment for a while you know and
variably are bringing something really
valuable to the table and so we kind of
want to hear about that and then what
was the second part of your question it
would be needs like recommendations a
recommended undergraduate saying if you
were that for it well one thing that
I'll say just being on on the committee
is that for people who've been out for a
while I've seen kind of a variety of you
know in some cases there are people will
ask someone who they've been working
with outside of academia you know to
write a letter because that person is
the best person to
what you've been doing recently and you
know there's always a danger if you know
that that you go to someone who is your
professor as an undergrad and they
because it's been a long stretch of time
they're not able to really dig in even
to their own memories of you in the
classroom or whatever so it's sort of a
combination that I if if you look at our
requirement that says two of your
letters must be academic
please don't interpret that as meaning I
must go back to the my history professor
from my junior year and undergraduate
that I have not seen spoken to or
correspondent with in ten years because
they won't they won't remember you and
even if they said yes their letter will
will not have any meaning because they
won't be able to produce anything that
will tell us whether you can succeed in
this program so ask you ask recommenders
who know you well and who can speak to
your ability to succeed at MIT and they
they may be academics but not someone
who we've taken a class with and that's
okay and if I can seize this moment to
answer the question that you haven't
asked yet but I know it's percolating
under there which is I've been out of
school for ten years and my GREs are
going to be terrible because I've been
out of school for ten years
what's your minimum GRE score and the
answer is we don't have one and we also
view every application in its own merits
so if you've been at school for ten
years and your GRE s looked a little bit
low of course because you've been
ten years we're not going to eliminate
someone just because their math scores a
little bit less than someone who just
came out of a bachelor's degree in them
so yes submit your GRE scores do your
best but don't panic and don't think
that we're gonna cross you off just
because of those boys I mean I think
just having been under admissions can be
a couple times um I'm the war on the one
hand experience that post undergraduate
is really usually looks quite good so
there is definitely strong interest in
the stuff that you are doing
that's what MIT is that is a strength if
you've done the interesting work and the
other hand we're all I think people are
there is sort of a look and say it's a
person ready to do graduate school work
in other words it doesn't mean that you
should have to come directly from
undergraduate the opposite but but it's
important that you can demonstrate that
you're ready to put a graduate student
for two years if you think you want to
come and just continue producing media
like you're doing right now that's not
what we're looking for so so do find
ways of demonstrating your capabilities
and student as well as
maybe I wrote myself like
well I would have spent 20 years I
usually win I that was a question I
asked everyone to talk to and I just
wrote I couldn't find it so I wrote
something I wrote like it I wrote
something but connected to the work I've
already been doing just to have a
writing sample so if you I don't know I
don't want to speak for the admissions
committee but what I was told is just
like if you have anything that could
demonstrate you can write and then I
remember asking the alumni panel when I
was here they were also closer to
graduating I think within five years of
school if you had something I think the
the main thing with the writing sample
you know it's for the admissions
committee the admissions committee wants
to see that you you know right but also
it's equally important to show some
amount of you know critical than
analytical you know critical analysis
and so I know that that comes up
sometimes in the you know in the
admissions committee and you know it's
it's kind of a combination of those two
things what what the writing sample acts
he's meant to convey to you
I'm actually really good I've been a
glad I'm a good company because I'm in
the out of school for over a decade club
as well and I was I saw that they
mentioned on the app that like if you
had taken classes that were like but I
guess related
what I had done in the past year is to
make sure that I was wanting to
and
like without
yeah just make sure you you it's
specified that it was an audited class
but you didn't receive a grade and you
know that's another thing that you might
want to work into your your statement
right you know that you were so
interested in particular you know
aspects of media or you know whatever
the topic was of those classes that you
know that you wanted to audit these
classes and what was it you know in
those classes that you feel like really
you know that you really got kind of
connected to or excited by that is now
kind of informing what you what you want
to do is ask
there's no sort of use for do you
certainly we've had students go right on
to PhD programs from from our program so
I'm assuming that puts it in good stead
with some PhD programs it probably has a
lot to do with what you and the food in
your thesis and I don't think it's you
know insofar as we try to we try to not
set you back financially when you come
here
I think it's not like you're you will
not have been wasting your time or your
money and again from the from the
standpoint of the admissions committee
if you are someone who is interested in
pursuing a PhD ultimately I think the
admission committee tends to want to
hear then why why this program now so
why is this student not going straight
into occasion
there's something that's specific about
this program you know which is not a
ph.d program that has you know a bit
more I would say potential for this kind
of engagement with both critical
analysis and production you know if
there's something about that that you
want to do before going forward to a PhD
right so yeah so again it's sort of one
of the questions for everyone entering
the program you know to try to think
about an address in your application is
why this program yeah I mean I've seen
people rejected and look really good and
are also playing lots of deep these deep
programs and the assumption is though
they probably really want PhD and so so
I think so just to amplify knowing why
you want to come to this program is
important to division school there's
been a question back here in one year so
when we start with human
yes yeah if they come in from all kinds
of backgrounds Yuri it's really
difficult to categorize see if you look
at my cohort as an example yeah it'd be
like one one person did a history
undergraduate Dartmouth another person
went to Harvard and yeah Museum Studies
one person came from game design in
sociology one questions a filmmaker one
person came from international like
media work like working in different UN
related sites doing communications one
person came from a tech maker background
mean yeah it's all over the one person
the documentaries a filmmaker but also
anthologies that's my cohort I don't
feel like from me knowing the cohorts
behind me and ahead of me
so much from the stem exactly yeah maybe
mark maybe one or two people with some
computer science or people who have
self-taught skills around technology but
nobody some not that in terms of a
purely stem
yeah it's that's a pure stem background
it's sort of a once in a while kind of
thing but we will get people who are
very technology center who come as well
as people who are very humanistic
so the second question yet you can take
courses from other other departments and
schools so we're comparative Media
Studies is under the School of
Humanities Arts and Social Sciences and
Media Lab which kind of physically
attached to our building is attached to
there is part of the School of
Architecture in architecture play you
know and there's there's the engineering
school there's there's a ph.d program in
what is it about that very long
humanities III anthropology science
technology and society yeah so and that
sort of emerged from the Science and
Technology studies connects people who
are interested in history anthropology
etcetera
so there you know there are other
graduate programs at MIT that you can
and the first part is about
collaboration is about in collaboration
which I mean I'd say it's uh sort of
catch-as-catch-can but frequently I've
seen where unawares graduates instead of
meeting graduate students and other
programs and finding some intersection
particularly because lots of the more
traditional sciences frequently their
funding includes a requirement for some
kind of public communication and so
there actually are opportunities to do
projects in which you are
I've designed games for it or what we're
largely engineering projects so it's
those kinds of operating them but they
can't happen I mean within the student
experience
maybe you can speak to this a bit more
because the because the curriculum in
the first year is fairly defined it does
take some effort I think to meet
graduate students who are outside of our
program you know among faculty there's
collaboration that happens as well but
yeah within among graduate students it
takes you know like I'm saying it kind
of it's possible but it takes a little
bit I think the first semester you
really you're locked in with your cohort
because you're taking all the classes
together but because there's the
consortium in most of your classes you
will have students memory you will have
most of my classes at least one or two
students from Harvard so just one other
Mick person in the mix or from another
department even like we also get where I
feel like we're in line or close to a CT
as well which is art culture technology
and there's some overlap there or
physically in the same space but
sometimes you need students from there
you might take a gym class of her
students how many people also depends
where you live like you live in a
graduate housing sometimes you have
opportunity people so I think it really
just depends on especially in the first
year the first semester is how much you
want
yourself there's a lot of opportunities
to deepen the relationship with arts
culture and technology is one that I
think is being right now is being
actively fostered in the sense that this
year for the first time as kind of a sub
series within the colloquium series we
have a series of speakers who are being
kind of brought into the colloquium as
part of a collaboration between one of
our faculty members and one of the
faculty members in arts culture and
technology but that's a series
specifically on I think it's called a
civic civic arts series so those are
speakers who are engaged with engaged in
some form of media production that is
also you know coming from an arts
perspective or background but which is
sort of using an artistic approach to
media technologies in the goal of kind
of civic engagement did that make sense
right and that has been a really
fruitful kind of collaboration both in
terms of that the speakers who have been
coming in and in terms of the
possibilities for I think for our
graduate students to meet graduate
students in a CT and it's in one of the
a CT spaces which is also a really great
kind of change
and I'll jump on that that the ability
to be interdisciplinary and and to work
with other students from all of these
Institute is always up to the individual
but that said MIT in general has an
enormous lis interdisciplinary attitude
every department every program at MIT
you will find people who have joint
appointments between two different
departments two different schools
sometimes the MIT Stata Center which is
the building that looks like it dropped
in out of a dr. Seuss book was
constructed specifically to force
different groups to encounter each other
on the first floor because of those
happy coincidences and and possible
collaborations so the atmosphere here at
the Institute is a very collaborative
one
we couldn't go between the first and
second year well so students tend to use
that summer in a variety of different
ways there are some courses right but
they're not typically VMs or things so
there's the short answer says no if MIT
offers courses over the summer but they
probably won't be anything that our
students would be interested in
and these Harvard summer courses are not
covered by the consortium agreement so
most of our students will either do
research in one of their research groups
over the summer or they will travel and
do their thesis research over the summer
also there are other programs at MIT
like misty which is like a study abroad
thing where depending that's something
you're looking to you can also get
certain types of funding to do other
research or like we get there's there's
a travel grant every year to go to a
conference it can be related to the
larger field of your research so some
people do thesis work over the summer
percentage questions what percentage of
the students do non-traditional project
days
and there the question was what
percentage have children yeah that's one
of the smaller percentages it's really
it's certainly not one every year yeah
they were after he thought I ya know he
had one
okay yeah yeah it's really not that we
specifically discouraged it's often very
daunting to think of parenting and
graduate school at the same time but
that said we have had people
successfully do it and graduate and
their children many would survive also
there's so many grad students here so
the people aren't longer bad for them
many of them have kids yeah and so in
the community at large there there are
people there are parents and all the
like community health and wellness
services are focused on the community at
MIT and that usually doesn't
differentiate between students staff
faculty so in terms of like being a
parent housing the dorms are not just
for singles so if somebody does come
with kids yeah they're they're a
babysitting networks within that housing
your other question about percentages
that are sort of mixed correctly that's
changed but students doing some
additional media production as part of
their thesis that's always secondary I
mean it has to be in the past it's
always has to had to be a written thesis
primarily and it's media production
somehow and form to that like I made
this thing and that's part of my
research that's happened but I wouldn't
come thinking I'll do a thesis that's
half doctor
having written thesis is it yeah that's
not the way it's been in the past I mean
it's been it's been slowly changing I
think but so that I feel like there it's
more frequent but but yeah it's not a
it's not a substitute for the writing I
know that in one of the cases one of the
recent cases that I was a Co Co advisor
on he's a boy
she you know she did a written project
and written pieces and was working on a
documentary film that was connected to
the same thing and so she you know cut I
think maybe a ten minute piece that was
that then she went on to used to you
know once she graduated to apply for
funding for the longer documentary and
she also had an element of her thesis
that made use of one of our colleague
Sasha Costanza shock a platform that
they developed for for using the phone
for you describe it well in this case
she used a phone line like an 800 number
in Turkey where her project was based to
for people to call in and share their
memories of this particular popular
media figure singer who was the most
popular singer in Turkey who was also
well who also cross dressed in sort of
the era and style of the bra
Liberace but within a very different
cultural context and so so Bayes I used
this platform that Sasha had created to
open an 800 number in Turkey for people
to call me and share their memories of
this figure and that ended up kind of
really blowing up and she had hundreds
of phone calls and she was able to then
take that take material from that that
came in over the phone line and weave it
into her written pieces so that that
became not just an additional component
but it was actually part of their search
process but all of that said William ury
Keo and I who were the code advisers on
that particular project did make some
some allowance for the fact that she had
produced these other two media
components in the sense that at the
level of a word count for her written
piece it was probably a little bit
shorter I don't know whether it ended up
I don't know you might know or at least
like we allow her to yeah but it wasn't
a lot shorter because she ended up once
she dug into it ended up you know
writing you know close to the same
length as everyone else but but there
was some allowance that we made
understanding that that that these media
components were part of the larger part
oh so the first part of the question how
many people how many people per cohort
in for eight to ten and then the second
question is the percentage of students
who are coming straight out of undergrad
with each year might be just one or two
and corner yeah yeah but it varies from
year to year and you know because some
years we have more applicants who are
directly out of undergrad and some years
not and you know again the deciding I
mean there's no kind of like fixed
number that we're looking for it's for
someone who's coming straight out of
undergrad like everyone else we want to
get a sense in their statement you know
why why graduate study why this program
why now and it may be that the in the
past some of the undergrads who have
relatively straight into our program you
know engaged in some some sort of work
as an undergrad that just got them
really passionate about a particular
aspect of of media that they wanted to
just continue with you know immediately
undergrad to like build on so again it
sort of comes down to you know what you
can convey to us about you know about
that trajectory
interruptive briefly with a question
from the interwebs that i think you guys
will be interested in somebody asked if
it was possible and if it was okay to
apply to two programs at the same time
if they were equally interested in CMS
and say a CTE or the navy lab and the
answer to that is yes absolutely it's
fine to apply to more than one program
at once in fact it's very common
because my concern is about the writing
sample is
yeah
I mean I think that that and you know
you might have other ideas as well but I
would say that you know if there is a
longer paper for example that you've
written for one of your undergrad
courses that a is something that you're
really that at the time at least and you
know ideally still is something that
you're really passionate about and where
you feel like you really dug into
something and you work really shine and
you know ideally something where we get
a sense of your you know depending on
you know even if it is specific to a
particular discipline to get a sense of
your critical analytical skills if it's
critical and analytical skills in
relation to some kind of a text via text
or written text or whatever then I mean
there although we have people whose
experiences you know runs the gamut you
know there are people whose main kind of
scholarly engagement like is you know
it's centered on you know the analysis
of media texts or you know it may be
that there's if you majored in history
that there's a paper where you are able
to demonstrate that particular you know
methodology or tribal research and you
know just so that we have a sense of
whatever discipline you went through
kind of you know what where you get to
show us your critical and analytical
skills within that discipline
yeah I think I remember reading them
just trying to evaluate the person as a
writer and a thinker and a researcher I
wasn't evaluation
so that there there are other
opportunities like in your personal
statement to talk about your future
interests the writing sample is really
there to show us that you are up to the
task in terms of the writing that's hard
it was it was for me personally it was a
very big shift
just because I'm several years out of
school and I ended a big project that I
was doing in New York and I've never not
lived in New York so for me you know
that's a tough question I know it was
hard to imagine what it was going to be
and now it's hard to imagine
I think I was nervous about the rigor
and how scary it would be though you
know the work especially already been
out of school and you know there was an
adjustment around it but I I genuinely I
like what I'm doing here and so it's a
good fit like like if you're not
interested in media and you know
especially it's tempting because this is
a funded program it's not for you
don't come in because you gotta like it
like you got in there there's some
nerding out here so yeah I mean I I
think what I what I think is great here
is like there's a casualness and access
like maybe that's just grad school at
large but like I've worked I've sent in
you can send an email to anybody
generally light you back like for
instance my friend came here to screen a
movie which MIT India helped organize
and they were they also worked in
education and I asked Justin could they
come and see the lab and they met with a
lab person there and they ended up
having a lot of synergy and it was just
really easy to do that yeah I don't know
I mean you know I'm I'm very
chauvinistic around
you know so the challenges in living
here are the challenges and they're not
being exhibition yeah that's what I
would say it's my diplomatic supply
everyone
but when he started the application
it's gotten a question specifically
there's a there's a couple of questions
that I always get after the fact so I
figure I'll answer them now residents
here
but they have to don't have to submit
their learners twice it's it's the
platform the application is the same but
it doesn't share any of the data between
the applications so your letter writers
would have to essentially write they can
use the text of the same letter but they
have to write in a submitted
they they do that on purpose because in
other platforms you would you would
click a link and the system would send
an email to your letter writer and they
found that they they were going into
people's spam boxes and that if the
email comes from you with a copy of the
paste in the text that it doesn't get
sucked into his fan box and your letter
writer actually gets the email I would
also encourage this because I've seen
seen this in applications is you know to
ask your letter right if you are finding
two different kinds of programs here to
make sure that your letter writers are
specific in each letter about you know
what they're recommending what program
they're recommending me to even if the
you know the body of the letter is
pretty much the same just so that every
now and then you'll get a letter where
there's maybe a big good PhD yeah yeah
and and you know even though you know
the strength of the leg it's a strong
letters and strong those are the kind of
things that that's kind of you know the
little details that they're the
application deadline is January 1st
take your GREs before December 30 if you
take them after December 15 we will not
get the scores in time
period
so just if you haven't taken the test
yet make sure you take it before
December
if you send it to any department at MIT
we will be able to access this course
good question if you are an
international student you will have to
click the Iowa's which is the
international regulation Language
Testing Service the minimum score is 7
and you don't necessarily have to have
the score sense you can provide the what
they call the testing report form the
TRF number in the application do not
wait until midnight on December 31st to
submit your application if you submit it
a day before them it gives me a chance
to eyeball it and see if there's
anything missing and let you know that
maybe all three letters are missing
maybe one is missing maybe your GRE
scores aren't in yet that being said
there's no particular advantage to
submitting submitting a month early
because blowing bully emissions of non
same experience we don't look at any of
the applications until after their
deadline you will be asked to submit a
financial statement in the application
that is not viewed by the admissions
committee
so it's an influence their decision at
all but we're also we fund our students
so it's not going to influence them
they want to ask you yes
PDF format yes that you can provide
links but just be careful that you test
your links before you submit them
because sometimes the links break that's
why I often prefer PDF remember the
portfolio is optional although I will
say that when someone's done a genuinely
interesting website it's worthwhile so
you might want to back it up with PDFs
but if you've got kind of something kind
of interesting going on on a website by
all these I created a portfolio website
yes admit and I did it like in like
Squarespace and made it really I've like
been trying to review my website for
like 15 years and then I just did a
quick portfolio site to highlight the
things that I got a role that was he
said if you have that kind of stuff yes
and there's some place in the
application right you could just say any
other information I also I mean just my
experience of the admissions committee
is that committee of themselves diverse
and so the reality is some people who
really have interesting creative work
will appeal to some people other people
are on those narrowly focused on sort of
the more academic side that's just their
different personalities of the different
readers you don't have to sort of later
to happen again so I would say certainly
if you've got any strengths play to them
I mean obviously there's no way of
guaranteeing who's gonna be on the
committee and what's gonna appeal to
them but you should certainly play to
your strengths
I think if the last thing would be that
if you if you write to see MSW
admissions and I might even your email
will come to me so in case you want a
face to go along with the question that
you're asking for help on it's my job to
answer these questions as my job to help
you get through the application process
successfully so please don't feel shy at
all if you hit a snag if you don't
understand something if you think
something is not quite right doing this
is the front line of the application
process yeah I know
so I think you know you take advantage
of like if you have questions that come
up out today
lightning hi
and everybody knows that you are all
cordially invited to the colloquium
evening which is our alumni panel good
luck everybody
protect your each other's in return
tomorrow yep Oh